old mafia guys think text link has
ruined the mob okay this is a this is a
true story old mafia guys think texting
has ruined the mob it's common knowledge
that the new york's infamous five
families aren't quite
what they used to be uh worn down by the
feds upstart competitors and a changing
world in general according to the wall
street journal though they have another
problem the goddamn youngs and their
cell phones this is truly the article i
just read the article the paper wrote
that today's new roster of gangsters
isn't exactly impressing the old guard
especially because some lacked the sense
to not leave incriminating text messages
or logs behind a new generation of wise
guys didn't properly
learn the business older members
complained that the millennials who grew
up in the suburbs instead of the city
streets are softer dumber and not as
loyal as mobsters of the past plus
they're always texting everything is on
the phone with them said a former made
uh member of the colombo family so
do you agree with these guys it's it's
well i mean gerard's half mafia i tell
you man go ahead i i do but i think it's
the camera phones more than anything
else that it's like there's kids i used
to coach and i would tell them like
listen you want to go to college college
coaches are going to scrub your social
media and like it's like i couldn't even
get the sentence out before we'd see
them on instagram or snapchat like yeah
at this party yeah vibing bro it's a
vibe and i'm like dude like there's
booze everywhere you're 16 what are you
doing
i just couldn't understand it on like
i couldn't wrap my brain around the
things i used to do to try to sneak into
the house
right and not be detected when i was out
with my friends or we had like a couple
drinks or something like that it took a
real skill though yeah and then you're
coming in and like you're doing the
mouthwash like your parents don't know
oh yeah yeah you're doing mouthwash
yeah exactly so they can get up to the
lines the things that we did to try to
keep our dirt secret and these guys
lived their whole life on front street i
you know good for them i guess man but i
can just see it i could see the
millennial mobster being like hey man
about to go ax this dude shouldn't have
done what he's doing like i got my gun
right i got my gun right here this is
the gun i'm using right now you know
what i remember that cause of no [ __ ]
bro remember the um the scene in um in
goodfellas when they when they do like
the big thing they go to layla for a
little while we don't need you you know
putting getting eyeballs on us and the
guy shows up in the big fur coat yeah
it's like i [ __ ] told you to lay low
what are you doing here
at this point it's because it's a sign
of the time social media snapchat
instagram tick tock yeah
if you did something and you don't put
it on social media did it even really
happen yeah so validation it's putting
out there like the cell phone has killed
the mob so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]